j'ai amélioré à koné
non
tourné en fait j'ai pas millions
om fgf vous êtes un million vous êtes
abonné à ma chaîne youtube et c'est tout
simplement un chiffre 2 malade mental
c'est juste incroyable
autant vous dire que je pensais vraiment
pas quand j'ai fait ma toute première
vidéo sur crysis 2 fin j'en ai fait une
autre avant que j'ai supprimé parce
qu'elle était vraiment trop des jeux
mais quand j'ai fait la vidéo sur crysis
2 et dont j'ai fait la première vidéo je
me suis montré je pensais jamais qu'un
jour un chantage fait que jouer des
coups de casque quand même qu'il y
aurait un million de personnes qui me
soutiennent
c'est incroyable j'ai des trucs de ouf
et je m'éclate à fermer vidéo a entre
guillemets à exercer ma passion et que
ça se dit absolument pas et tout ça
c'est grâce à vous tous qui m'a
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
sans la savane car le malaise qui je
m'envoie des couches fait n'importe quoi
la palme est trop vite tu parles
importante et très beaux jours des
tricots de sulu mais bien entendu
patrick ailleurs ces bons revenus
j'ai coupé l'aco et 9 juillet théâtre
on se prend le cubique yes c'est un
débat elle sans rudy qu'il veut pas
signer mais il est pas mal fait on sans
déconner pour un jeu indépendant pu
taper dessus car c'est bon les internes
c'est une perte de temps mais on allège
de 5 centimes chacun c'est pour toi mon
gars
non pas mais on a trop fait genre qu'on
bouge pas attends attends regarde le
loin il va arriver
regarder vers le haut ils arrivent ils
arrivent sculpté tout pas encore atteint
tandis que faire leur arrivée tout ce
monde et guy dubois va regarder il fait
chaud alors c'est quoi ça pourquoi la
partie senior pause et au non non
là c'est possible de passer tout notre
seigneur ainsi garder parce
qu'aujourd'hui les filles je veux
apprendre à faire de la corde à sauter
le but de bébé trop mal je n'ai pas fait
un bruit singes dans ses pas on va
mettre un bruit de singe ça aurait fait
aussi peur en fait
où aller tu peux pas bien m
ce genre allez arrête bonne chose c'est
ton crâne tarente été le cas mais on m'a
volé mon cartable mais qu'est ce qui
t'arrive attend juste de calais un poids
mais qu'est ce que tu as à temps je sais
j'étais décoince tiens ta passion je me
couchais mais papa watts
les gens nous sommes
amadou tigana
faire la poissons de merde peut-être
cette ultime
ils voulaient 5 kg merde je sais capable
de voir un mouton sous l'eau là comme ça
d'un coup là par la gauche s'est vu ça
on va prendre la fille albane morel va
nous porter chance
elle a des mains de bonhomme cuche les
fesses en plus ça et je les prie pour
regarder regardez là comme elle touche
c'est fait
oh non non c'était signe de bidos
j'espère beaucoup d'éclairs bien
connecté après une belle bataille des
colis et maintenant comparons ce bruit à
un cris de singe
qu'est-ce que ça foutait là
le site web a pas déjà fait montre en
outre le portable
oh non
garder le sens quand nous permet de
regarder oui je sens une présence
terrain
canif york m qu'est ce qui bloque 9
tonne 1 5 m me forster a ajouté ma et
regardez loger plus à l'est
moi je suis un crabe
mais qu'a fait je la fais exprès de
mettre un bonhomme comme ça qu'ils
passent ils vont soit obligé d'attendre
qui passe pour pouvoir continuer le jeu
et ça c'était pour faire rager les moins
sensibles aux dépêche toi ou alors la
fin est ce que vous allez en fait
peut-être sa tête comme ça et bien
d'autres les quais blood en lui au
regard des prix fermes sur la main ça
fait rien ouah ouah mais quelle est
cette arnaque
non maintenant je veux pas d'un couple
elle avait déjà essayé ça c'est moi je
fais dans ce blog n'ont laissé moi non
je ne fais pas ma couplé avec vous non
plus puis d'erc et pas du tout en état
de choc a fait des mois et en hommes
violés on savait qu'on avait tout le
temps je perds ce parce qu'il ya des
futurs sites de marans et le crescendo
que tu peux avoir quand tu te met à
chanter tu dois ce niveau tu fais ta ta
ta ta ta ta
1 2 3 soleil 1 2 3 soleil de trond
sollied 1 3 soleil fera qu'au cas où les
réflexes
tout est tombé sur un ton de foot les
entailles milliards à oyo et lila et
paysannes jack lawrence est papa pour y
aller oh oh là là haut ça mérite le cul
mais tellement france vient de se passer
ohlala mon dieu mon dieu ramenez-moi du
dac en émoi du tac tu es puni
tu as oublié ton bonnet d'âne mais moi
je ne veux pas te rejoindre mega fin s
est auto tu vois tu la fais ton plus
beau profil
il avait demandé une chirurgie
esthétique excuse moi tu sais et est
avec toi tu te réveilles pas je t'éclate
ce bocal sur ta gueule on est déjà passé
par ok on peut faire une marelle mais
oui mais bien la petite araignée a les
genoux décidé une petite mare elle voilà
c'est parti et à cette espèce de bruit
de chasse d'eau en font l'un est
horrible il nous faut une ambiance
sonore terrifiante pour notre jeu
m j'ai plusieurs questions à propos de
ce jeu la première pourquoi la personne
qui regarde elle est un coach
pourquoi c'est pas top mais c'est quoi
ce délire
sauvé débuté la danse du mec juste la
super dur ce match est à la tête à ok
je suis là
on n'a pas dès mardi
pas pour le mcdo a dit je te fais la
cour me battant nous allons bien à plat
et voilà c'est déjà terminé j'espère en
tout cas que ce bazar pour que je fais
ça j'espère que ça vous aura rappelé de
bons moments passés devant votre ordi en
tout cas moi oui c'était vraiment des
[ __ ] de fou rire que j'ai passés de
france cet ordi à faire ces vidéos
et puis on se retrouve bientôt dans deux
nouvelles vidéos qui j'espère vous
plairont aussi hein parce que oui c'est
important
en tout cas merci d'être si nombreux et
de me faire vivre ce que je vis
actuellement parce que c'est juste
incroyable
et puis on se retrouve bientôt dans une
nouvelle vidéo tu as tout manque plus à
bientôt
portez vous bien et pourquoi j'ai fait
ce geste totalement débile